نبقى في الضفه الغربيه اذ افاد الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني باصابه 14 فلسطينيا
بحاله اختناق وذلك في مواجهات اندلعت عقب
اقتحام قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الليله
بلده عقربه في جنوب نابلس بالضفه الغربيه
وسط اطلاق كثيف لقنابل الغاز المسيل
للدموع والصوت وقامت قوات الاحتلال بتفجير
منزل عائله الاسير الفلسطيني اسامه بني
فضل بعد ان اجبرتها والعائلات المجاوره
على اخلاء منازلهم كما استدعت قواه
الاحتلال امام مسجد عمر بن الخطاب المقابل
للمنزل المستهدف واخلت المسجد من المصلين
واجبرته على اغلاق المسجد وهو ما ادى الى
اندلاع مواجهات بين شبان الفلسطينيين
وقوات الاحتلال وسط البلده اطلقت خلالها
القوات الاسرائيليه قنابل الغاز المسيل
للدموع والصوت بكثافه نحو الشبان واعتقلت
ثلاثه
منهم اصيب عدد من المصلين الفلسطينيين
بحالات اختناق وحروق داخل الحرم
الابراهيمي الشريف في مدينه الخليل جنوب
الضفه الغربيه بعد مهاجمتهم من قبل
مستوطنين بالفلفل الحارق وكان عدد من
المستوطنين قد اقتحموا الحرم ووسط مدينه
الخليل بحمايه جنود من قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وشرعوا برش غاز الفلفل الحارق
على عدد من المصلين اثناء تاديته لصلاه
العشاء ابو حسن
ماله من جهه اخرى افاد مراسل الجزيره بان
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اقتحمت فجر
اليوم مخيم الفوار جنوب مدينه الخليل في
الضفه الغربيه ودهمت ازقه وعددا من
المنازل كما اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال المنطقه
الجنوبيه من مدينه الخليل ودهمت عددا من
المنازل وفتشتها واعتقلت عددا من
المواطنين وكانت قبل ذلك قد اقتحمت قوات
الاحتلال بلدتي صوريف وبيت امر في شمال
مدينه الخليل وبلده بني نعيم في ش
شرقيها ينضم الينا من الخليل مراسل
الجزيره منتصر نصار مرحبا منتصر الخليل
كانت واحده من المدن في الضفه الغربيه
التي شهدت اقتحامات كثيره طالت عديد مدنها
وقراها اشرح لنا ما الذي حدث خلال هذه
الليله نعم محمد بالفعل الخليل كانت هذه
الليله على موعد مع اقتحامات عديده لاكثر
من منطقه تركزت في شمال المحافظه انتقالا
الى وسطها وصولا الى جنوبها ودعني ابدا من
مخيم الفوار جنوب الخليل الذي شهد اقتحاما
موسعا هذه الليله قوات الاحتلال داهمت عدد
من منازل المواطنين اعتقلت المواطن وعد
ابو ديه وابن عمه بعد ان اقتحمت المخيم
بعدد كبير من جنود مشاو باليات ايضا
انسحبت عند عند اذان فجر هذا اليوم من
المخيم بعد تسجيل حالتين اعتقال ومداهم
وتفتيش لعدد من المنازل في شمال مدينه
الخليل بلدتي بتمر وصري اقتحمه الاحتلال
هذه الليله وصادر عدد من المركبات في بلده
صوريف وفي بلده بتمر شمال الخليل ونفذ
حمله تفتيش ومداهم لعدد من منازل
المواطنين كما داهم المنطقه الجنوبيه في
مدينه الخليل ايضا و هناك الحديث عن تسجيل
اربع حالات اعتقال في المنطقه الجنوبيه
بمدينه الخليل كان في وقت سابق الليله
الماضيه اقتحم بلده بيت عو جنوب الخليل
وصادر عدد كبير من المركبات كانت
قوه من اليات عسكريه ترافقها ونشات مخصصه
لحمل المركبات اقتحمت بلده بتعوا وصادرت
عدد كبير من المركبات طبعا هذه البلده
تشهد منذ عره ايام او اكثر بشكل يومي
وليلي حملات مصادره مستمره ومتواصله
لمركبات المواطنين الابرز والاهم في
الخليل ايضا الليله الماضيه وعند الانتهاء
من صلاه العشاء مستوطنون قاموا برش غاز
الفلفل الحارق باتجاه المصلين الذين ادوا
صلاه العشاء في المسجد الابراهيمي الشريف
في مدينه الخليل على اثر ذلك اصيب اثنين
من المسنين الذين كانوا في المسجد نقل الى
العلاج شكرا جزيلا لك منتصر نصار مراسل
الجزيره كنت معنا من الخليل